>> Dana: DEMOCRATS ATTEMPT TO
PUBLICLY SHAME TRUMP VOTERS.
HE IS CLAIMING THAT HE AND
OTHERS HAVE NOW RAISED OVER
$1 MILLION FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NO NUMBERS SHOW THE PRESIDENTS
CAMPAIGN IS BEING FUNDED BY
SMALL DOLLAR DONATIONS.
IT IS COMING FROM DONATIONS OVER
$200.
THIS IS NOT STOPPING DEMOCRATS
FROM TRYING TO CUT OFF.
SUGGESTS THAT IMPEACHMENT MIGHT
BE THE WAY TO DO IT.
>> IF HE HAS NOT DEFEATED IN THE
SENATE, HE WILL STILL RUN AS AN
IMPEACHED PRESIDENT.
AND THERE WILL BE A GOOD MANY
PEOPLE WHO WON'T WANT TO HOLD
FUND-RAISERS FOR HIM.
WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO ARE
BENEFITING FROM HIS BIGOTRY.
>> Dana: BUT MARK, GOING FOR
IMPEACHMENT COULD ACTUALLY FUEL
TRUMPS DONOR BASE EVEN MORE.
>> Mark: BRING IT ON, LOSER.
LAST TIME AROUND, AS THIS TIME
AROUND, HE GETS HIS MONEY IN
SMALL DONATIONS IN A WAY THAT
MET RAW     TO MITT ROMNEY CONAN
MET RAW     TO MITT ROMNEY CONAT
MET RAW     TO MITT ROMNEY CONA.
BIG DEAL.
HE WILL STILL GET HIS DONATIONS,
AND THAT'S WHAT HE DID LAST
TIME, AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
HE'S NOT A DONOR CANDIDATE.
>> Dana: WELL, HE IS A DONOR
CANDIDATE THIS TIME AROUND.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO HELD BACK,
THEY HAVE ALL GIVEN THIS TIME.
>> Mark: THEY ARE GETTING ON
THE BANDWAGON AFTER.
>> Dana: I'M NOT ARGUING THAT.
BUT IT'S NOT THAT THEY ARE
HOLDING BACK, EVERYONE IS ALL I
IN.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CAPITALIZE ON
THAT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THE REPUBLICANS FINALLY HAVE A
COUNTER TO WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
CALL ACT BLUE.
THEY CALL IT WHEN READ.
ANOTHER $20.
THEY MADE A TON OF MONEY ON THE
T-SHIRTS.
>> IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
THE FOLKS ON THE LEFT AREN'T
USED TO HAVING TO DEAL WITH
CANDIDATES ON THE RIGHT.
THEY ARE SEEN GRASS ROOTS
SUPPORT.
THAT'S VERY DANGEROUS FOR
COMPETITION, BECAUSE THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GO OUT AND VOTE.
THOSE GRASSROOTS SUPPORTERS GET
REALLY PASSIONATE AROUND
ELECTION TIME.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF ALL OF
THESE LEFT-WINGERS DON'T
SECRETLY WORK FOR TRUMP, BECAUSE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY ARE DOING.
YOU'VE GOT BILL BARR OUT THERE
CALLING FOR A RECESSION, THAT
HURT SO MANY OF HIS VIEWERS, ARE
MIDDLE-CLASS VIEWERS.
YOU'VE GOT LEFT-WING
COMMENTATORS CALLING TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S RACIST.
NOW YOU HAVE LEFT-WING
POLITICIANS ACTIVELY GOING
AFTER.
IT'S LIKE, I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY COULD TRY ANY HARDER TO GET
TRUMP ELECTED.
>> Dana: WE ONLY HAVE LIKE
AMENDED AND A HALF LEFT.
LET ME GRAB GREG.
>> Greg: NUMBER ONE, TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT THE RADICAL NATURE
OF TRUMPS MACHINE.
THE TRUMP-PENCE WEBSITE.
LOOK, IF YOU ARE ON THE FENCE
ABOUT ANYTHING, YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THE LEFT IS
DOING.
THEY ARE SANCTIONING A DOMESTIC
TRADE WAR.
THEY ARE WAGING A TRADE WAR
AGAINST THEIR NADIR DOMINIC
NEIGHBORS.
THE LEFT IS COMPLYING THE
BIGOTED MOVEMENT TO THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THAT IS A TRADE WAR.
THAT IS JUST GOING TO PUSH THE
MARGINALIZED TO GIVE MORE MONEY
TO TRUMP.
SPEAK TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER
GIVEN MONEY BEFORE.
REMEMBER WHEN ELIZABETH MORAN
GAVE THE BIG SPEECH ON THE FLOOR
AND MITCH McCONNELL ASKED HER
TO YIELD AND NEVERTHELESS, SHE
PERSISTED.
THE DEMOCRATS MADE SO MUCH MONEY
OFF OF THOSE T-SHIRTS.
>> Juan: THE REALITY IS THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAD A TWO YEAR
JUMP ON EVERYONE IN TERMS OF
FUND-RAISING.
HE DOESN'T HAVE REALLY A PRIMARY
CHALLENGE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN RAISING
MONEY.
THE BIG MONEY FOR TRUMP AS LIKE
THIS WEEKEND IN THE HAMPTONS
WHERE IT WAS $250,000 A TICKET.
THAT'S TYPICAL.
>> Dana: IT IS NOW.
>> Juan: TYPICAL, AFTER
CITIZENS UNITED, THE AMOUNT OF
OUTSIDE MONEY, TRUMP HAS A HUGE
LEAD OVER THE DEMOCRATS FROM BIG
DONORS WHO DON'T NECESSARILY
IDENTIFY.
THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY IS
COMING.
BUT YEAH, I JUST THINK THAT WE
SAY, OH, TRUMP HAS THE SURGE IN
TERMS OF THESE SMALL DONORS.
THE SMALL DONORS ARE BEING DRAWN
IN WITH THINGS LIKE T-SHIRTS AND
THE LIKE.
BUT THE BIG MONEY COMES FROM
GUYS WHO SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, I
GOT THAT TAX BREAK.
I GOT A HUGE TAX BREAK AND